so I'll be telling you about some of the
applications of machine learning
especially in healthcare settings so I'm
assistant professor here at Stanford my
name is James so and a lot of my group
works on actually developing and
deploying such the AI systems for
biomedical and for healthcare
applications
right so feel free to stop me if you
have questions at any point
so what I want to do today is to just
firstly give you a few examples right a
few case studies of like how what kind
of AI systems are we using and deploying
in healthcare settings and also talk a
bit about then what are the some of the
challenges in actually building AI
systems for healthcare applications
right
um so the first example I want to give
is actually based on this paper that we
published a couple years ago it's on a
computer vision system that we developed
for assessing heart conditions
right so the idea here is that you know
there are these kind of ultrasound
videos so if you go to the Stanford
Hospital right or most of the hospitals
they'll take a lot of these kind of
ultrasound videos which is looking at
the human heart
um and we developed the system to
basically read these ultrasound videos
right and based on these videos to
assess the different cardiac conditions
of the patient
and the system is also now being uh we
develop the system as published and then
we spent a lot much of the last two
years in trying to actually deploy this
at different parts of Stanford for
example that's a setup that we have
using the sets the emergency department
here at Stanford
okay so so how does this work right
um so if you think about these
ultrasounds videos right this car
cardiac ultrasound also called
echocardiogram so an example of this is
shown on the left here right
um so if you think about like the hearts
as like a power pump right so the
standard way to estimate like how much
power the heart is generating especially
by looking at these ultrasound videos
right so there are actually millions of
these videos are being collected every
year around the US and the current
workflow is that the cardiologist The
Physician would actually look at these
videos and they would try to identify
you know which frame of the video where
the heart this chamber of the heart is
actually the most expanded where it's
the largest and also try to identify the
frame where the chamber is the smallest
right and by looking at how much the
volume of the heart changes from going
from the largest to the smallest then
they can get an estimate of how much
power the heart is producing right if
you think of the hardest like a pump
so um so as you can imagine that process
can be quite
um labor intensive because it's quite
manual right because they have to go
through an entire video by hand and then
once they find the frame they have to
actually Trace out the boundaries of the
chamber right to figure out its volume
of the on the of the Chamber of the
hearts uh all of those steps currently
is down basically with sort of manual
annotations
um so this is where we thought like
these kind of machine learning
applications especially computer vision
can be very useful right so we developed
a system called Echo net right and what
econaut does is to basically mimic this
clinical workflow right so it takes its
input the same kind of cardiac
ultrasound videos like the one we see
here right so it produces like a
real-time segmentation of the relevant
chamber of the heart which is the one
that's shown in blue right in addition
in addition to doing this real-time
segmentation of the heart chamber it
also produces like a real-time
assessment right of how much power the
heart is producing which is technically
called this ejection fraction so that's
the first thing is shown here
uh so by doing this is sort of really
simplifies and automates these different
manual parts of the clinical workflow
oh
so no I wouldn't go into too much detail
of how the algorithm the details of the
algorithm but it shares like a high
level overview of what it's doing right
so it's basically taking input these
videos right
um and they're basically two sort of
components right of the algorithms it's
like the top arm and then the bottom arm
so the top arm is basically looking
through these videos using a spatial con
spatial temporal convolutional Network
right so it's because it's a video so we
have both the spatial information right
for in the given frame how big the
chamber is there's also the temporal
dynamical information
right so this is sort of a modification
of the standard kinds of confidence you
probably typically have seen on imagenet
type applications by adding an
additional Dimension corresponds to this
to capture the temporal Dynamics
okay so so it's sort of like a
three-dimensional convolution in that
sense right so it's going through that
in the top enter extract the features in
the bottom is basically doing this
real-time segmentation
right so it's basically producing like a
segmentation of this chamber of the
heart that was colored in blue
right and these two arms will come
together at the end right to make like a
actual real-time assessment for how much
power or the ejection fraction of the
hearts for Every Beat
right because once you have the
segmentation for every you know every
beat right so you can actually then sort
of assess the power
so after it does this assessment right
so there's a final classification layer
where it's actually trying to predict
all sorts of relevant and interesting
clinical interesting
um cardiac phenotypes right so there's
like the probability of heart failure or
you can predict that you can also assess
the ejection fraction which again so
basically how much power the heart is
producing and so it turns out that we
can also use the same kind of layer to
predict all sorts of other functions
like liver or kidney function because it
turns out that see once you know how the
heart is doing that you can actually
learn a lot about the rest of the body
Yeah question
I guess
he wants me to do with sequence we do
something like that resonance
but sometimes how do you decide
yeah so it's a great question
um so here if you look at these videos
right so the heart is actually pretty
repetitive right you know you know
roughly about every once a second where
the heart will expand and contract so
there's actually a lot of repetitive
spatial information right which actually
makes it quite well suitable for these
kind of more convolutional architectures
which are looking for these the spatial
patterns or you know or temporal
patterns
and here in particular we basically are
looking at the time scale of basically
once every second right so the we get
maybe around say I think 60 frames per
second right
um and then so for every second then we
make like a one assessment of of like
the ejection fracture and also the
assessment of the heart condition for
every individual beat which is about
once a second
and then what happens in the end is that
you know you have a for every bit of the
hard drive we get an assessment of okay
so how much power is that heart
producing and How likely the hardest
have different diseases right the video
itself actually could have multiple
seconds right you can actually capture
many beats right so at the end we
actually do like aggregation across all
of those speeds to say uh holistically
for the patient then what is the status
of the patient
thank you
cool other questions
great
um so this is the system now that's
actually used and developed here using
Stanford and data from Stanford and we
also test the system both at Stanford
and at other hospitals right so one of
the places we tested especially in the
hospital in Los Angeles Cedar Sinai
um and you know we just took the
algorithm without any modification and
then just shipped it to Cedars right and
then to see how what did it do right and
we're actually quite happy to see that
even without any modification right on a
different hospital where they had
different ways of collecting these
images collecting videos and data right
the algorithm actually had very similar
performance as it did at Stanford right
so the AUC is quite high it's about
Point uh 0.96
all right
okay so that's the first example
um
any any questions about that
okay so the second example I want to
briefly mention right is an application
of AI more for a telemedicine or
Telehealth applications
so what is Telehealth right so that in
normal settings or usually if uh you
know if if you have some sickness or if
the patient has some illness right
they'll actually come in to visit the
doctors in person right
um but recently last few years there's
been uh explosion of the need for
visiting and having patient doctor
interactions not in person but through
uh you know digital formats right
especially without having to digit
number start having the patients needing
to leave their homes
as you can imagine that really the need
for these kind of Telehealth or
telemedicine applications have really
expanded especially during the pandemic
right so for example this at Stanford in
Stanford hospital so just over the last
two years there's actually something
like a 50 fold increase the number of
these digital or televisits right
compared to about two years ago
so one of the you know so telemedicine
could potentially be really
transformative for healthcare right it
means imagine like not having to
actually leave your home and drive an
hour to come to Stanford right much
easier to see doctors and also make
appointments
um one big challenge right was
telemedicine in general is the idea that
you know can you actually get
sufficient information
without having the doctor seeing the
patient in person
right
um and in particular like oftentimes
right lots of information that the
doctor gets is by you know sort of
visual interactions with the patient if
I actually see you face to face then you
can often examine them quite closely
and that's difficult to do with you know
when you're doing this on on Zoom where
you know through some other video visits
so and that's really one of the big
challenges Telehealth is in getting high
quality images right from the patient to
the doctors
and for example at Stanford there are
actually a large number of visits that
are wasted right so patients will set up
a visit with a doctor but then the
doctor is not able to get sufficiently
good quality images from the patient
right so so then they can't really make
it informed
recommendation or informed diagnosis
right and then they have to sort of
reschedule when we turn that back into
like in-person visits so there's
actually a large number of hours both by
the patient and Physicians that's wasted
because of this lack of quality images
so what we want to do is to basically um
you know see can we actually use machine
learning and social especially about
using computer vision to improve the
quality right of these images for
specifically for this Telehealth type
applications
right because it turns out that you know
people are very good at taking photos
for their Instagrams and for their
Facebook but maybe they're not so good
at taking photos that are clinical
quality with our eie like of that are
informative for this clinical decision
making process right so the idea is can
we actually use machine learning to
guide people and help people to take
more clinically informative images
that's a lot of the motivation behind
this um algorithm that we developed it's
called True Image right which has also
been sort of commercialized through
Stanford's
um and so the motivation is quite
intuitive right so similar to how like
online check check deposit works right
so idea is that you know we want
something that's very simple it can be
run on you know on people's phones and
then it would automatically tell people
like you know is the image that you're
taking maybe off your skin Legion right
is that sufficiently high quality for
your dermatologist right for your
clinical visits if it's not so good
quality then the algorithm actually
provides real-time feedback right
guidance to the patient on how to
improve the quality right maybe it says
that you want to zoom in a bit more or
you want to move to the closer to the
window to get better lighting right so
provide these real-time guidance until
they get sufficiently high quality
right
um so yeah so basically the True Image
algorithm is you know it's uh so it
basically runs right it's designed to be
run sort of at the patient's facing side
right so maybe like so the patients
could be taking a photo right of their
you know of their skin and then they
want to use that to send it to their
dermatologist for their televisions
right and the outputs obviously was
decide like if the photo is sufficiently
good quality right if it's sufficiently
good quality then that's fine right so
the image just goes through as normal if
it's not so good quality right the
algorithm would decide okay how does
give a recommendation to the patient
right say how do you actually improve
the quality of your photo in this case
maybe it says that's okay you can move
to a brighter lighting right and the
patient will retake that uh and if it's
good enough then no it's surf passed
through the algorithm
it's a setup an application clear to
people
okay
um so a little bit more about under the
um
okay I'll just jumped into the sort of
the how do we how well does this work
right so the algorithm
we actually conducted like a prospective
study here at Stanford right um
perspective study means like there's
actually like a real-time study where we
recruit the patients they use these
tools it's almost like a clinical trial
right so this is done in the dermatology
clinics that Stanford operates
um and we tested this on maybe about 100
patients right
um and it was actually quite effective
right so by the patients using this
algorithm they were able to basically
filter out but 80 percent right of the
poor quality photos which are IE like
photos that are
um they would have sent to the clinician
but otherwise would have been sort of
useless by the clinician because there
are not sufficient high quality to
actually make a meaningful informed
diagnosis
right
um it's also nice that this is actually
very fast right so on average it takes
actually like less than a minute for a
patient right to generate a high quality
image by going using the stream image
algorithm
um and this is the sort of an example of
the kinds of improvements that you see
here right so maybe like this it's like
an initial image that someone would
actually really would take and send it
to to their doctors for these Telehealth
applications
right for these one of these Telehealth
visits
um and you know that True Image
algorithm identify that though this
image has the following issues with the
blur and the lighting it makes a
recommendation and then after using the
algorithm right the patient actually
have much better image that um now would
facilitate their televisit
so this is actually being now uh it was
tested at Stanford in dermatology
settings right and it's also being
integrated now into the Stanford Medical
Records
cool
any questions about this before we move
on
yes
this is pretty useful
easy just based on it yeah but beyond
that are there any other like readily
convertible fields in this exactly like
oftentimes you need to be a doctor
assistant looking at your throat or
something interesting things yeah
yeah so it's a good question so I think
Dermatology is probably the the most
immediate application of this right
um
there are also
a few others or from like Primary Care
settings right where often the doctors
actually get more information just by
inspecting what the patients look like
and how they're how they behave right so
this is where it could also be useful
for other settings where if it actually
requires taking a biopsy of the patient
right for more like pathology or you
know cancer diagnosis Beyond skin cancer
then
um then the patient will still have to
come in to the visit
yeah so it's a good question so uh so
what the algorithm does is that it
actually does incorporate quite a bit of
domain knowledge so one of the
developers on our team for doing this
she's actually one of my postdoc with
the dermatologist
so she sees patients one day a week and
we actually did our initial piloting of
this in her Dermatology Clinic
all right so for example the kinds of
domain knowledge that comes in will be
uh first we actually you know take the
image and we first segment out this just
the skin part of the image right because
if you take an image there could be all
sorts of background right maybe our
Furnitures and chairs and we don't
really care about the quality of those
backgrounds so if you segment out to the
relevant human skin
um and to identify and after we stick
about the human skin right and then we
also try to map onto what we think are
the likely issues towards the image if
there are issues right so oftentimes the
things that come in would be like is the
image does it have enough lighting right
so the kinds of lighting that's required
for a dermatologist is actually quite
different from the lighting that's you
know for on the standard photos so
that's actually one place where often
people make mistakes right and another
place where the expert analogy is very
useful is in terms of how much Zoom is
needed right sometimes if people zoom in
too much that's actually not so good
because then they lose the context of
the surrounding like if you just zoom in
Only onto your legion then you lose the
context of the uh this neighboring parts
of the skin or if it's too zoomed out
you also don't have enough information
right so there's like an optimal Zoom
which we get basically actually by so
the way that we train two images is
actually by having dermatologists uh
generating annotations about what is
like the optimal Zoom from like a
database of of images
cool yeah good questions
um it's like another example it's very
quickly mentioned it's um we've also
been developing these algorithms for uh
using machine learning to improve
clinical trials right so clinical trials
are like the most expensive parts of of
medicine right each trial could actually
cost hundreds of millions of dollars to
run right and sort of like they're
really the bottleneck of this entire
biomedical translation process right so
one place where we found that where
machine learning can be very useful is
in helping these clinical trial or
helping the drug companies to decide
what are the a good sets of patients to
enroll in a given clinical trial because
you want the patients to be that they're
diverse right so they really cover
diverse populations and also that's the
drugs likely to be safe and effective
right for that set of patients right so
this is basically a tool that we
developed called trial Pathfinder
and you know for helping to guide the
designs of the clinical trial
specifically the designs of the which
cohorts of patients are eligible to
participate in a clinical trial and this
is being piloted Now by some of our
collaborators and Partners at Roche
Genentech which is the largest biopharma
company
and if you're interested the more
details are described in this paper
good so
now that we've talked about a few
examples right of where machine learning
can be used in healthcare settings and
where in case having
a substantial impact I would also like
to discuss some of the challenges and
opportunities that arise when we
actually think about deploying machine
learning in practice
right because you know in in 229 we
talked a lot about actually how to build
these algorithms right and there's also
a lot of interesting challenges you know
I've rebuilt them thinking about how do
we actually really deploy and use them
in practice
so just to set the stage I want to give
you like a concrete example with sort of
like a little detective story right so
here's the story right so um you know I
mentioned this Dermatology aif
applications right so the Dermatology is
actually one area where there's been
sort of the most intense interests and
investments in developing AI algorithms
right precisely because the data there
is relatively easy to collect
and oftentimes these algorithm also work
as follows right you take your photo
then maybe of a legion right you can
take your phone and take that photo and
then behind the scene here there will be
some sort of
often like a convolutional neural
network right this looks through this
photo and try to classify it's just
likely to be cancer or not
right so in this case it actually
predicts that it's likely to be melanoma
so it's skin cancer and the
recommendation is that the patient the
user should go visit the dermatologist
as soon as possible
okay so the reason why this is useful
right is that there are actually several
millions of people every year who have
skin cancer but they're not diagnosed
until it's too late
our skin cancer if you diagnosed it
early on then it's actually very
treatable but if it's too late then it's
deadly
right and potentially many of these
people right they actually could have
made earlier diagnosis uh no because
they all have many of them have access
to not be able to take these photos
so that's the reason why there's a lot
of interest now both by academic groups
and also by commercial companies like
Google again pushing out like these kind
of AI for Dermatology applications
so of course oh yes go ahead one
question
so do you what's the target consumers
this is like the ordinary patient or
it's actually the doctor because
I mean if there's something growing on
your skin I mean like I think your
status to actually show a doctor or
something like that
so what what is your target base yeah
yes good question so there are
algorithms there people are putting out
that are consumer facing right there
also alcoholisms that are more
clinician-facing so most of these ones
here are actually more consumer facing
and the reason is that to actually make
an appointment to see a dermatologist
could be like a three months or six
month wait wait time yeah uh whereas uh
maybe people just they don't want to
make a visit every time they see
something because they don't know if
it's like to be serious or not so
basically for that kind of applications
where a lot of these consumer facing
algorithms are being put out
yes
just focusing because we all do we don't
want people that actually has the cancer
signal but be classified as like uh now
yeah so that from here probably like
what what if the absence
is that's possible that is anything
successful Hardware produced Maybe
yes yes it's a good question
um so here I'm Tony showing like sort of
the AUC of these algorithms from their
original Publications and papers
and in addition to AUC people also care
quite a bit about like the sensitivity
and specificity which I also mentioned
in a bit right and in particular I think
the sensitivity is probably the
important thing here a sensitivity here
means that if the patient actually has
skin cancer
how often would algorithm say that they
actually do have skin cancer right so
that's actually really the important
part if you you know if patient doesn't
have skin cancer and the opposition says
you have skin cancer that's not great
but it's actually not too bad right
because maybe they'll get a check then
they say it's it's okay but if you
actually miss the diagnosis and that can
be
um more potentially like more more more
damaging to the health
Okay so
you know given that there's a lot of
interest in algorithms certainly we're
interested in thinking about how to
potentially use them and deploy them
here at Stanford right
um so we actually took three of these
state-of-art Dermatology AI models right
they're all solving this task of you
know given photo predict whether it's
malignant or benign right skin cancer or
healthy
um
and we tried trading out here at
Stanford right so if you look at the
original algorithms they all have very
good performance right so AUC is very
high
um
however when we tested them at Stanford
on real Stanford patients right the
performance is suddenly dropped off
quite a bit right it's much worse as the
aec dropped from like 0.9 to 0.6
okay so let's sort of the the setting of
this little detective story right so
what we want to understand is okay so
why did this happen right why did these
algorithms performance perform so
importantly on Stanford patients because
we really need to understand that if we
really want to be able to use this in a
responsible way in practice
and just to be clear here right so these
are actually just you know images from
real Stanford patients right there's no
sort of adversarial perturbations or
attacks down on top of these images
so before I tell you what we found right
um what's this people actually like to
guess like what do you think are the
some potential reasons why the
algorithms performance dropped off so
much when they're applied on the real
patients
any ideas
a lot of times
so
like when it was in real patients it was
0.93 and my life wasn't Stanford
equations it was 0.6 for this was uh is
that our Stanford Creations were the
real patient information
so the 0.93 was
the performance of these models on their
original test data so the original test
data also came from you know real
patients that these companies or these
groups have collected that 0.6 is the
performance of this algorithms right
when you apply them to actually stand
for patients
[Music]
was a test data taken from a different
types of different types
okay so that so that could be one fossil
Factor like is there some differences
like temporal differences in data sets
oh yeah go ahead
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
okay so that's also a good idea so maybe
there's like some age differences
between the original test patients and
the Stanford test patients
yes
for both people
okay okay so that's also a good idea so
maybe there's some changes in the
location which drives different
distributions of diseases right skin
diseases that are more common here
these are good ideas
um there's a yeah any other suggestions
yeah okay
okay so that's also a good idea so maybe
there's some uh differences in like what
kinds of cameras were used or how the
quality of the images across these the
original test data and the data here
yeah
so these are all good ideas about
there's actually a couple of really big
factors
that are haven't been talked about yet
people want to say more
days
[Music]
okay okay
so maybe there's some caution but
whether the models are being overfit or
not into the original test data
okay yeah so these are all
excellent suggestions
so you know we actually did sort of a
systematic analysis like an audit to try
to figure out what happened here
um
and the goal of this audit right
mathematically is that we really want to
explain this drop off the performance
right so we see about today let's travel
from 0.93 to this point six I will want
to understand what are the factors that
statistically explain right this
difference in the model's Behavior
so I actually think of one of the the
biggest single factor is actually label
mistakes
right uh so what does that mean
so it if you look at the original test
data
right the data that was used to evaluate
these original algorithms right in their
initial Publications
so it turned out that there is no test
data
had a lot of mistakes in their
annotations
all right so what happened was that's
the test data were generated by having
these Dermatology images right and then
they would have dermatologists to
visually look at the image and say okay
is this benign or is this malignant
because that's relatively easy to
collect right
however just even having expressed
dermatologists visually look at images
can also lead to a lot of mistakes
right so the actual ground truth
uh come from you take a biopsy of the
patient and then do a pathology test to
say does this patient have skin cancer
or not
all right so that's what ground truth
from the biopsy is basically the the
labels that we have here at Stanford
right but the labels from the original
test data actually had a lot of noise in
them because they were just coming from
these visual inspections
right so and this actually explains
quite a bit of the drop of the model's
performance
and this is maybe not something that's
um that's sort of the first thing that
comes to mind if you think about like
somebody build a test data set and they
evaluate it we're oftentimes in machine
learning right we just assume that's
okay the test data should be pretty
clean should be good right but in
practice uh the quality of the label
itself in the test data can often be
highly variable depends on the real
world applications
all right so the first question that we
should always ask is okay so how good is
the quality of the test labels right how
good is the quality of the test data
so a second big factor which people
mentioned right is that there is
actually a distribution shift in the
different types of diseases
right so the original test data o has
relatively common kind of skin diseases
again because it's relatively easy to
collect
the data here we have at Stanford has
both common and also less common
diseases right because all sorts of
people come to Stanford to get treatment
right and the algorithms perform worse
on the less common diseases right and
because of this distribution shift it's
also explains to some of the drop-off in
the model's performance
so the third factor is that actually
turned out that these algorithms
um had significantly worse performance
when applied to images from darker skin
patients
right so specifically if you look at the
actual the sensitivity death model which
as we said is what we really care about
if a patient has skin cancer How likely
is it to find those skin cancer right
this the so the sensitivity is actually
much lower when the algorithms are
applied to images that come from dark
skin patients
and you know we dug deeper into this it
turns out that that's the original
training and test data sets had very few
and in some cases zero images that come
from darker skin individuals
right
and no that's just I think the overall
takeaway here is that oftentimes when we
look at the application of machine
learning in real world in practice right
um
it's very difficult to interpret the
performance level model right so if
someone just tell you their AUC right
it's very it's almost meaningless unless
you really know the context of what is
the data that's used to evaluate that
model
so here I talk about you know the
Dermatology settings but we actually did
sort of similar kinds of audits of all
of the medical AI algorithms that are
approved by the FDA
so so as of last year right there's like
over 100 medical AI systems that were
approved by the FDA so they can be used
in on patients
so each symbol here corresponds to you
know one of these algorithms right and
here I'm just stratifying them by which
body part they apply to
right so some of them apply to you know
to the chest or to the heart
Etc
so there's a bunch of interesting
findings we have from other things
algorithms but I just wanted to
highlight maybe a couple of the Salient
points
just for today right so the most
interesting things may just look at the
color right so I colored each of these
algorithms uh blue if the algorithm
actually I reported evaluation
performance across multiple locations
maybe from multiple hospitals
or otherwise it's colored Gray
so it's already quite clear right that
most of these algorithms are over 90 up
to 130 did not report or couldn't find
the evaluation performance across
multiple locations right we only see how
well does it work at one site
okay in addition to that right so four
out of these only four of these 130
devices were tested using a prospective
study right by perspective I mean more
like a human in the loop study right so
they had the algorithm and they tested
how well does this work you know uh in a
real setting was was maybe doctors were
as patients
so the remaining the 126 of 130 were
only tested on for retrospective data
right and that means that's now somebody
collected like a benchmark data set
beforehand and then they apply the
algorithm to that Benchmark data sets so
retrospective Benchmark data set could
actually have come from the same
hospital where the algorithm was being
trained or developed
since we saw from the previous example
in dermatology setting right so if you
only have data from one location that's
collected retrospectively right that can
potentially mask substantial limitations
for biases in these models
okay
any questions
yourself
yeah it's a good question
um this is actually something that we
are working together with the FDA on
right so the FDA has a
quite rigorous process for evaluating
drugs right for example like
for the covet vaccine to be approved at
the FDA they have to run like a very
large scale randomized
clinical trial right and to show that
the drugs are safe and effective
the evolution standards for medical AI
algorithms by the FDA is actually quite
different compared to like drugs right
so for example these algorithms they do
not have to go through like a
prospective clinical trial right it
doesn't have to be randomized in a
clinical control right so that's why
many of them were tested on these just
retrospectively collected like Benchmark
data sets
right so one of the interesting
challenge going forward is to figure out
what's that feel like what's the proper
way to
evaluate and to monitor these algorithms
in practice
okay so now given that these challenges
that we we saw here right
um so I just want to quickly go through
a few lessons that we've learned uh or
recommendations that we have for how do
we improve the reliability right or
trustworthiness of these AIS especially
as they're being deployed in healthcare
or biomedical context
right now based on some of our
experiences from both building deploying
and also evaluating these models
so I'll say a little bit a couple of
slides about each of these points right
so the first one is that I think as we
saw that there needs to be a much
greater amount of transparency about
what data is actually used to Benchmark
or test each of these algorithms
right
um so for example just to give you a
concrete visualization of this so we
actually did a survey analysis of what
are all the different types of data that
are used to Benchmark Dermatology AI
models
right so now each Square here
corresponds to one of these Dermatology
AI models right this is where people
have published the paper on this right
and so that's the square so that are the
models for the papers right so the
circles are the data sets okay so the
size of a circle corresponds to how big
that data set is
and there are two colors right so the
red circles are basically the private
data sets which means that these are
data set that someone could be a company
or academic group that has curated but
they're private so that nobody really
has access to it
and then the blue ones
um
circles corresponds to the public data
set so these are like the the openly
available Benchmark data sets
right so for example one here it would
be like a relatively large public data
said it's often used by many of these
algorithms for benchmarking
and what's quite interesting is that
there's actually a large number of these
algorithms maybe about half of them
right that's um were mostly tested or
entirely tested um relatively small
actually private data sets
right basically like all of those ones
on the on the top right
all right and those are the ones where
it's actually could be
potentially problematic right because
then it's actually very hard for people
to audit and to understand like what's
going on enough data and what's going on
in these algorithms
so you know so we've been very keen to
try to uh release much more like
publicly available data sets right so no
I mentioned that we built this thermal
uh this Cardiology video algorithm and
actually as a part of that paper we had
created and released I think one of the
maybe the largest publicly available
Medical Data medical video data sets
right so it has basically all of the
videos that we trained and tested on
right so we released all of those
there's over 10 000 videos along with
the patient's information and
annotations
right so this is all publicly available
so that people can use this for
additional research I think this is
still maybe one of the largest public
data set of medical videos
okay so in addition to understanding
what data goes to developing the models
right so we're also very interested in
thinking about you know more
quantitative ways to understand how to
different types of data contribute to
the performance or to biases of the
models
right so what does that mean right so
from a machine learning or statistical
perspective right oftentimes you have
your training data right here you have
these different each symbol could be
like one of these sources of training
Dynamic data from a particular Hospital
right and then you have your favorite
learning algorithm so we're a model
agnostic or it could be a deep learning
model or could be XG boost random Forest
right and you have whatever performance
metric that you care about in deployment
it could be accuracy or some sort of
loss or F1 score
and let's say if your model actually
gets you know 80 accuracy
right so ideally what I want to do is to
be able to partition that 80 accuracy
back to my individual training
you know individual data sources of my
training set right so I want to say that
oh how much each of the data points for
Insurance data sources contribute to the
model's performance
and the reason why that's useful is that
you know if the mod or if the model
actually makes mistakes right in
deployment or if exhibits biases in
deployment as we saw right then we also
want to be able to say very
quantitatively like what specific
training image or training Source
actually are responsible for introducing
those biases or mistakes in the model's
Behavior
right so if we can actually do this end
to end from the data to the model and
then going back to the data right so
then this will make the whole system
much more accountable and more
transparent
okay so you know in a bunch of Works um
you know with my students we have
actually developed sort of approaches
for doing this right for exactly trying
to do this data valuation uh it's based
on these ideas we're calling sort of
data chaply scores
so the idea here is that we're able to
sort of compute a score for each
training point right could be a training
image and the score will actually
quantify how much how much does that
image contribute to the model's Behavior
either positively or negatively in
deployment
right so this is for example if we use
our Dermatology as our running example
right so the training set could be quite
heterogeneous could be quite noisy as we
saw right and the models trained on this
could have relatively poor performance
when it's deployed in clinical settings
so data Shuffle score that we propose
actually would just be like a number a
score for each of my training image
right the score could be negative right
if that image is somehow not informative
or contains some misadmentations or
introduce some sort of outliers or bias
to the model
right so the model if it's trimmed down
that image actually does worse
and the positive scores right indicate
that these are the images the training
points that are informative such that
when the models train down those images
they actually learn and do better in
deployment it's actually capturing some
informative signals
right so these Japanese scores can then
be computed throughout the efficiently
on these different data on individual
data instances
and this is actually quite useful also
for improving the model's reliability
right because one thing that we can do
now is to you know weight my training
data
by the Japanese scores right so a simple
idea that we after we complete the
sharpiece course a simple experiment
that we can do is to just take the
original model and just retrain the
model on the same data set except now
I'm waiting each data point by their
shafly scores so this has the effects of
encouraging the model to pay more
attention to data points that have high
chapty scores right which are the again
the data points that we believe are the
more informative uh or have better
annotations
right and by doing this this action
actually can substantially improve how
well the model Works in deployment
settings
right and the benefit of this approach
is that it's quite data efficient right
because we just still have the same data
set we didn't have to go out and collect
a new data set right we'll have the same
data sets and actually the same model
architecture the only difference now is
that the same model architecture is now
being trained on a weighted version of
the data rather than the vanilla kind of
training
okay
so
so those stars are you know two I think
quite complementary ideas right once we
want to be much more transparent about
what the data is coming from right and
what's the data Shuffle scores this
helps us to understand how do the
different types of data really
quantitatively contribute to the model's
behavior and by understanding that
contribution let's also give us ways to
quickly improve the model's performance
um so the third lesson we learned
actually quite important is actually
really useful
to try to really understand why does the
model make specific mistakes
right because as a general message if we
want to
ensure that the AI systems that we
deploy are safe or responsible it's
actually the mistakes that are the most
revealing right we want to look at
because by looking at the mistakes we
can actually understand what are the
potential blind spots where the
weaknesses what the limitations of the
model
um so we developed a bunch of algorithms
to try to basically provide more
high-level natural language explanations
for why does the model make specific
mistakes as a way to teach us about
blind spots of these machine learning
models
so here's one example right so let's say
if you've actually put in this image so
image the true label is uh zebra but if
you put it in this image whereas a lot
of the outputs almost some of them will
make a mistake and predict this to be a
crocodile rather than zebra
right and in this case we'd like to
understand why okay why did that happen
and this to work so the explanation we
provide using this tool that we call
sort of uh you know conceptual
explanation of mistakes it's actually
automatically generates a reason for why
the model made the mistake in this
context right so in this case it's
because there's not actually too much
water in the image
right so in other words if the image
this image has less water and maybe more
field right then it would actually have
gotten the model could have gotten the
correct prediction of zebra rather than
crocodile
right so you can view this conceptual
this mistake explainer sort of like a
raptor around in a different computer
vision you know AI systems right so it
takes one of these AI systems right and
looks at the mistakes the models make
and then it provides like this high
level natural language explanation for
why did the model make that mistake on
that input
so this is quite useful because then we
can apply our AI explainer right this
mistake explainer to also sort of
explain you know why did some of these
Dermatology models make mistakes on
these different users on these different
kind of patient image
um so here are actually Four example
inputs right where the original
Dermatology AI classifier made wrong
predictions so the correct diagnosis the
correct label is written on top and what
models the predict is written on the
second line
and in each of these examples right so
our mistake explainers or automatically
provides uh sort of a reasoning of why
the model actually made that mistake
so for example in the first example
right so we learned that the reason why
this model actually made the wrong
prediction here is actually directly
because of the skin tone
right so it's it's
um
uh because of the darkness of the skin
tone so in other words right if the skin
actually had been lighter right or else
being equal then the model would have
actually gotten the correct prediction
in the second example right so explainer
learned that it's really because of the
blur in the image that led to the model
to make that mistake
right and if the image at the same image
had been sharper right the explainer
learned that then the model would have
actually gotten the correct prediction
which is on top
so in the third example it's because of
the zoom right so it turned out that
it's actually too zoomed out and that's
really the reason why the the classifier
made those mistakes and the fourth
example is because of there's like two
it's too much hair in the image
right and despite actually understanding
why the models made these mistakes in
each of these specific instances
this actually gave us quite a lot of
insights into potential limitations and
blind spots of the model
right here we've already learned that
and potentially it doesn't really work
well on dark skins uh it really needs to
have pretty Crisp Images it can't be
blurry and there's certain level of Zoom
that it needs in order to make this
diagnosis and also if there's too much
hair in the image then that doesn't the
model doesn't really work well
right and this insights are actually
pretty actionable right for example you
can then take these insights and then as
a guideline to help the users to improve
their image quality right so that's
maybe you actually tell the human users
like we did with True Image right you
want to zoom in a bit more or you want
to
um you know take sharper images right it
could also give us insights on you know
if we want to collect additional data
right what additional data should we
collect in order to improve the model's
Behavior across these different and
improve their weaknesses
right maybe we want to collect you know
more diverse images across different
skin tones we also want to maybe collect
more training data with more like hair
in it
foreign
that we need to have much more
human Loop analysis and testing of these
AI models
right because if you think about how
Machinery is often developed right
um I think it's often optimizing for the
wrong objectives
because most of the time right you have
a data set that's fixed the static data
sets right then algorithms optimized you
know with SGD try to optimize for its
performance on on that static data set
that's actually not what you really care
about right it's what you really care
about is actually how well the algorithm
really works in the real world
applications which oftentimes it's not
really in isolation right but it was
some team of human users especially in
healthcare setting like most of these
outwards on the top right here right
they're not just working isolation but
there's often some clinician who takes
the input from the takes the
recommendation from the algorithm and
then make some final decisions
right so in the ideal setting what you
would really like to optimize over is
maybe some to like an SGD right to
optimize the model's performance
directly for their final uh usage right
rather than under accuracy on the static
Benchmark data set
um but that's actually challenging to do
right
so to address this challenge what we
developed
um these platforms called radio which
actually makes it very easy to collect
real-time
feedback right from users at all sorts
of different stages of my model
development
right so basically it was one line of
python code right we can basically
create a wrapper around any machine
learning model and this wrapper also
creates like a interactive user
interface right which can then be shared
like as a URL with any user right so if
they open up that URL then they can just
interact with the model in real time on
their browser without having to download
any any data or having to download or
write any code
right and by doing this right that makes
it very easy for even for non-computer
scientists to be able to interactively
engage with the model right to test it
out and provide feedback on you know of
the sort that we discovered that we
discussed before
okay so creative is actually now
um
now is recently acquired by hugging face
but still public right and it's also
being used by basically all of the
larger major attack companies
and the many thousands of machine
learning teams
it's also what we use to power some of
our own like deployments here at
Stanford
so just to summarize right so I think
these are sort of the four
main key lessons that we learned from
our experiences in applying in building
and deploying and auditing these AI
models right uh no I talk a lot of here
about applications in healthcare
settings but I think many of these have
lessons and applications also apply more
broadly in other
other domains where machine learning is
being used
okay and all of the papers and the sort
of the the algorithms I mentioned are
all available on my website and here
again are the different references and I
also want to thank the students a lot of
these works
so maybe we'll pause here and then
see if people have any more questions
[Applause]
paper button
yeah yeah good so the hell of ideas that
we want to estimate the impact of
individual data points right and we do
this by basically adding and moving into
this data points across different
contacts right so in each context I
basically have a different subset of my
data right and then say okay so what's
the impact of adding this particular
data point to that subset right if I add
this point that's an improve my model's
performance before after adding a
compared to before adding it
uh and we do this basically across a lot
of different scenarios each scenario
corresponds to a different random subset
of my training data and the reason why
we do this across many scenarios is to
really capture potential different
interactions between different data
points
and then back then we finally aggregate
across all these different scenarios to
get one single score the data shopping
score for each individual training point
the snc you have to retrain the model
multiple times with different subsets of
the data and I'd evaluate them on your
test to see how they detect an
individual yeah so
in principle if you want to do this
exactly then you need to retrain the
model many times so we actually came up
with a bunch of different efficient more
efficient algorithms that enables us to
estimate the sharpiece score so without
having to retrain the models right so
for example in some other applications
we can actually come up with sort of
analytic mathematical formulas right to
either exactly or approximately compute
the shaftly values without having to
retrain the models
yes I
have a review party
um
that's right yeah so the original ideas
for these kind of shafly values actually
came from economics from Game Theory
where they're the people are interested
in ideas of how to allocate credits
among different users or among different
participants in the game right so
imagine if all of us if we solve we do a
course projects and we get some bonus
and how do you split about that bonus
about each of the individual
participants so that people don't
complain people they're happy with their
bonus so it's developed in that context
of more like Game Theory credit
allocation
um and we extended that idea to the
context of the data right now instead of
having individual workers or
participants now I've based everybody
brings their own data sets so data is
what works together to train the machine
learning model basically the performance
now is basically how what is the bonuses
how well does the model perform right so
then we can see okay so how do you
allocate or attribute the performance
the model back to the individual data
sources or individual data sets
cool any other questions
yeah um
[Music]
did it tell you are those pre-provided
by the team or are those like generally
attached Me by that novel
yeah it's a good question so
what we have is basically we have a
library of Concepts right uh like what
we call like a concept bank so basically
we can look at all the sorts of common
visual concepts like the concept of
water or concept of stripes or concept
of zoom and color right so those are OB
Concepts right so I'm going to create
like a
pretty large library of hundreds of
these Concepts right and then those then
that's basically the input into the
explainer as the explainers try to see
okay so what of these Concepts would
actually be able to explain the model's
mistakes
in cases where the concept that we
provide are not complete but maybe
there's some texture information right
the that actually leads to the mistake
but it's not in our concept Bank we'll
have some additional ways to try to
automatically learn Concepts right in a
more unsupervised way directly from the
data
for most of the concepts we use are
actually you know from these large
concept banks that we can just learn
ahead of time
okay great yeah and then we can wrap up
here